what the heck
if they don't say yes
i don't know what i'm gonna do i need to
get some sort of tonight we'll have to
spend everything you've got on this
deposit what's the worst that can happen
the worst of cameras you get rejected
most bosses they don't want their
employees to be rich
never seen this many property deals
being done before it's been crazy
[Music]
multi-millionaire property investors
samuel leeds is back at it again with
another financial freedom challenge with
five days on the clock one lucky
employee is about to have their life
changed forever as usual samuel will be
using his 10 plus years of property
investing knowledge and training to help
someone become financially free in less
than a week samuel started from scratch
in sheffield blackpool london manchester
northern ireland new york city he's a
man on a mission and he won't rest till
the job is done so sit back mute your
friends and family members and get ready
to take notes from this all new
financial freedom challenge
who knows
will you be next
[Music]
right so what we need to do is we need
to basically get i'm thinking the
strategy service accommodation does not
work in central london very easily
without planning permission so we can do
a rent around but i'm thinking of rent
to hmo right okay close to here
that's what i'm thinking so if you get
the computer started up yes let's get
some deals find some deals and hit the
road and see what we can do today
so
what is a wrench what is a rental hmm so
it's basically a rent to rent so where
you rent a property off a landlord you
do it as like a hmm
my favorite way to do this is to find
landlords
who are tired
if you find an existing hmn in london
yeah
but a bit of a bit of a crappy one like
it needs a bit of a tarting up a bit of
sprucing but the landlord's trying to do
it themself
self-managing landlords are the best so
some of these they look really nice yeah
they're boosted they look really nice i
wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily go to
those ones i would find some that are
just a little bit yeah
which are self-managed does that make
sense yeah so that's ah it's all that
looks terrible
yes that looks terrible but what you
have to spend quite like for that to
look better you have to put like nice
carpets in and
yeah but not much not much money you'd
be surprised at how cheap it is to rent
out this is a current flattening so that
would be a potential
a prospect you call them up yeah uh
again this one like they've not even
bothered to put like there's no color on
it it's rubbish
resume living that boom you could call
resume straight away
rather than thinking too much or worried
about look at that terrible
yeah
call them live out landlord perfect
right so that's one way to get landlords
details
and then you're gonna ring them up and
you're gonna go i'm a company i'd like
to just offer you a complete guaranteed
rent
oh can i book a view it right now
open rent same story open rent is like
um right move but for landlords direct
again
boom
so the studios but we're gonna you can
you can find shares you can do shared
only and find all the nasty looking
shared ones
like that's nasty
that's nasty look how look how bland it
is yeah
right so 900 pounds so you can just ring
don't worry too much about the property
we just need to speak to landlords you'd
be amazed um i mean you can do this as
well london hmo
register okay you can literally find
every single licensed hmo
in the entire of london look regis
register of licensed houses
look at the rate look and you can just
see
register of register of life the
problems with this though
is if you
boom
look at this look at this
mr davinda girl that's his address hmo
address
the problem is we haven't got phone
numbers so for us to write letters to
these people is going to take too long
yeah
really nice way is gumtree
like we did yesterday and you can just
search for properties in in london so
you just i'm looking for property
to rent yeah
in london
[Music]
crazy there's quite a different like a
few different options there is
there is
like look at this um and you can
you know three three double bedrooms
boom
three bedrooms
number there three rooms you could
probably rent the rooms out
for and they look terrible
for like a grand a month or more wow
look at that
it's terrible
another way
really good way is to go to the facebook
marketplace this is my favorite way this
is just incredible okay so why would you
put it watch it on facebook do you know
what i mean this facebook every weird
place to put it
on
look at this property for rent
people put properties on facebook look
at this
all these properties
okay room for rent in three bed flat
asap
so there's a three bed flight it looks
dinger we can spice it up a little bit
give them a guaranteed for the entire
thing so there's so many and the thing
is when you stop calling people look
three double rooms
five fifty all right all right all of
them
that's in brackel court london i don't
know where that is okay so you just need
to hit the phone speak to landlords tell
them you're a company that can offer a
guaranteed rent don't agree a price to
pay them on the phone say let's meet at
the property let's have a chat let's
look around the property see if we can
offer something of value look four beds
650 a month
we could rent each room each room for
6.50
wow and the whole thing's 6 50. that's
ridiculous now maybe it's not maybe i've
missed something maybe there's a problem
maybe there's damp everywhere but just
pick up the phone book viewings message
them on facebook call them up and i want
you to fill the afternoon up okay with
hmos and landlords and we'll speak to
them as many as we can let's see what we
can do i'm on it alright
[Music]
hey samuel amelia how you guys doing
[Music]
why would i bother do it why would i
give you one of my properties
for you to
to take to right now so i'm basically
looking to do to rent a rent and
obviously i know that you have kind of a
lot of hmos and you're a busy guy
so i'm hoping to to come in and
basically make a a win-to-win situation
where you know you can have peace of
mind you don't have the hassle and i can
deal with everything i have a number of
hmos right okay and um probably
represent just under 100 units okay in
london yeah or within the 15-minute
drive in my office here
and so um
i have agents that find me tense they
used to be all managed by a well-known
agency
and so what happened was um
um i think they just weren't doing a
good job of it so they're kind of easing
off that but i've got another agent who
finds me
tenants they find a tenant they put the
tenant into the property and i pretty
much manage it from there
and so it's just a question of really
doing their maintenance etc etc
uh yeah the other but generally speaking
it's not a tough gig because they're
never too far away only 10-15 minutes
away
and um you know it's just making stuff
isn't i mean you get the border checks
out once a year
so i can understand you saying that some
landlords might be stressed out or
overwhelmed yeah is there any other
advantage you could give me because i'm
not particularly stressed out i'm not
particularly overwhelmed so
how else could you
yeah i think that the kind of value that
i i hope to bring to you yeah it's just
not necessarily that you might might be
stressed out but just like i could take
that off your mind so you should focus
on other things like you were saying you
want to convert there you kind of got
all the bigger plans so you kind of got
the hmo kind of box tick so it's more
that i can come in it's not necessarily
that you might be struggling with it or
you're just coming and and be a bit of a
help test so talk me about some figures
what sort of things you're looking at so
i'd want to make it a minimum of 500
pounds profit
um per deal and like you said like
obviously i
you know
me taking one off you might not be that
much of you know an amazing thing
because you're already managing the
others but what i could do is we could
try it out on one property you could see
how you find it and whether you think it
you know i'm being a help and whether
you see the value and then we can
obviously have discussions after of if
there's any further away so generally
speaking i'm not so sure that's
something i'm necessarily excited about
okay for the reasons i've given you and
because they're pretty much easy
most of my hmos are full okay
um i would say
my most troublesome hmo i would spend
maybe an hour to two hours a week on
okay which isn't
you know time wise under any
circumstances
could rent to rent work for you or would
it just is that not a model that would
ever work i doubt it because i don't
have any stress remember pretty
straightforward because the thing is i
guess rent to rent yeah what we're doing
works really well when you've got a a
motivated tired landlord that's like
i've got time i'm too busy and it's a
bit empty and it's a bit
and then you're getting profit and then
the landlord's got a peace of mind and
ease but with with you because you've
got a really good system yeah um see
most of my hmos i might have some where
i've got one room sticking or something
like first this one and the agent says
you just need to paint it if you paint
it the room will go yeah that's a seven
bed hml so six rooms already filled
it's just this one
absolutely
all right
i felt intimidated did you because it's
just like it's so weird because
obviously you're
massive in property but i know you so i
don't feel like intimidated talking to
you because i know you i work with you
yeah but when i talk to a landlord and
he's like you know i've got
i just often went in my shell and i was
just like i just didn't know what to say
i was mixing up my words i thought you
did really well i thought you did really
well yeah
i don't think we'll get a deal from him
yeah but he might put us in touch with
someone that we can he's very well
connected in london yeah yeah yeah he's
a big player yeah so
yeah let's see well done good job it's
not about getting a deal sometimes what
it is but it's also about
taking the action pitching doing it
see more people see more people see more
people the more people we can speak to
the more houses we can get in more
likely we're going to get a deal
so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
can you see that guy getting arrested
[ __ ]
flipping out they're fully coughing it
whenever they're so this morning we have
been in croydon um and to be honest the
viewings i had it just wasn't really
working out in croydon um so now we are
relocating to clapham
to try and find something there and i'm
super excited to be honest because
if i can find it
i basically found on the property
investors with samuel leeds group um a
bit of a lead it's a weird one because
basically there's this lady called
samantha who has a rent to rent on a
property um and it's been going really
well but she's moving out of the area
so the landlord wants to find someone
else to do a rent to rent on the
property uh so she's basically posting
on the facebook group um so yeah
obviously that's a massively strong lead
because they're actually looking for
somebody to event to rent on the
property um and clapham is just such a
good area like the demand is crazy like
i've looked into it and the property is
a clapham junction and on spare room
there's only 17 properties
that are going for rent so
i think it's going to be a really really
good um yeah it's a good lead whether i
can actually secure it is uh yeah
another another situation that i need to
deal with
hello
hi thanks for taking the call it's
emilia
about the renter to hmo hi how are you
hi i'm mckay
yeah really well thank you
what we can offer is 2
400 pound a month guaranteed rent and so
that means no void periods no hassle um
and also obviously we'll manage and
maintain the property uh up to up to a
certain agreed amount um
and then yeah basically we can we can
take over the property uh as soon as
really um and yeah basically get the get
the ball rolling does that sound good
yeah absolutely
happy with that in terms of the the the
actual setup it would be we would pay 2
400 we take care of all little bits and
bobs maintenance
guaranteed rent
um
we'd pay the bills and then we would
then rent the rooms out to individual
professional tenants who we would vet we
would monitor we would take deposits
from uh we would inspect them regularly
and um
our profit comes from you know if we're
renting the rooms out for 9 950 a month
we're going to make a little bit of
profit each month of course because
we're a business um but then from your
point of view you're getting a
guaranteed um 2 400 a month so that's
kind of the the general proposal so um
what what do you mean
all sounds good she will send you an
email with the contracts
um and the company details and
everything like that and then yeah we'll
um we'll we'll get everything all all
wrapped up
cool nice one all right great all right
great stuff speak soon bye-bye
can you believe catching
pound a month you'll make on that yeah
conservatives oh i'm literally you will
need to manage that one yourself yeah
yeah i'm literally picturing i don't i
honestly don't even know what to say
to the exactly
three and a half big bottom line and
going up from there since the sun has
just gone up and up and up and up and
this is where we're getting people
literally queuing on the street to see
properties
when we get something on we'll have
10 15 20 people viewing it as soon as
they're watching people are taking
things off the back of videos yeah
um
so yeah that's true
it's in better condition than i was
thinking in my hair
um
no that's great so we're definitely
looking i mean easily something north of
three and a half thousand
um at the moment so you think her room
i'm probably not looking at anything
less than kind of 8 15. yeah 900 yeah
that is crazy so basically
just went in to a hmo manager in clapham
and she's just said minimum minimum for
the property they'll just see 3 500
for renting it out and obviously the
lady that we spoke to today samantha
said that we could have it for her
property for 2400 the one that she's
renting out with a minute is it is this
the one on facebook yeah
[Applause]
so that was my due diligence i've also
looked online and done a little bit more
so i think i honestly think i need to
secure that deal before somebody else
does because it's clearly a very good
deal
day two baby here in london i live in
london and i know if we did like renting
out per night in like king's cross it'd
obviously do
ridiculously well the problem with with
greater london with london itself is
that if we're in london you need to get
planning permission okay to rent a
property out on short stairlets
service accommodation hotel without
staff this whole strategy
there's a 90-day rule in london so if we
do can you so you can't rent it for 90
days you can rent we could do rent to
rent hmo but if we're wanting to list it
on booking.com and airbnb
and get short stays no you can't do in
london does it you can do it for only 90
days a year heathrow wins that let's
just start hitting these towns yeah and
then going into all the agents saying
the same thing but this time we need to
get a viewing today
once finished recording please press the
key
hi my name is emilia asante i'm looking
to view the property that i've seen of
yours um in windsor the two bed flat
um yeah i'm just wondering if you're
available at all today i'm looking for a
property in the area and so yeah give me
a call back on oh
it's because it's too you say speaking
too long
yeah
i've never had um
a nap
tell me to show up
yeah it's like
[ __ ] you're talking too long are you
telling me a life story
would you be looking to put two people
into the reception rooms yeah yeah right
okay
all right lovely thanks i hope to hear
from you soon if not but that's fine and
keep you posted
the first uh first walk-in first
rejection yeah what do you reckon
i think it was awful i think it was
awful well she was like
i think she was trying to be polite but
obviously she was oh they're very polite
in beckham's field it was like a no
thank you dear we don't do that yeah but
she was friends as soon as we said oh we
might put people in the reception room
yeah she was like close the book thank
you but you know what you know what
though
that's the worst that can happen the
worst occurrence you get rejected yeah
we told her we're really upfront what we
do she said
doesn't really work so would you just go
in another agent i mean there's only
about four agents here and then we'll
have to go into another town
[Music]
a little bit of a unique sort of
situation
so i wondered if uh maybe we could have
a chat and tell you a little bit more
about what we're doing
see if you can help us
that's fine so i was just wondering if
you um have any properties that might
work on a the landlord will consider on
a company left okay okay so you've got
two two bedrooms
at the moment
[Music]
oh that would be really good go to
heathrow go to slow go to maidenhead go
to marlow all these little areas as long
as hotels are full then our service
departments are going to be full as well
two bedroom house all right ring them
just say can i view it today and just
before before he says yes or if he's oh
i could
just slip in oh it's going to be a
company i'm not going to live there
myself but yeah 2 o'clock's great i look
forward to seeing you there
come on man
we just need a viewing
that's a brilliant property
right but that's what we want to do
well done good job
oh man
excuse me do you know where the estate
agents are
okay near the castle
let's go thank you man
one at the top by the castle let's go to
the castle and let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
run down that airbnb and that kind of
thing there's like short stays yeah
we can it just depends on the landlord
what i can do i can get them details put
them onto our system and then if we do
if we do have any then of course
which is basically where we are right
now
let's look at other properties available
so these properties yeah 135 pound a
night
oh
marina's place on airbnb is usually
fully booked why like wait what like
surely there's like hotels in that area
don't people just go and stay in like
the actual hotels well we just went into
that hotel and it's being refurbished
yeah i mean they'll do a hotel or
they'll do if you go on booking.com and
you look at all the accommodation
available yeah most of them these days
aren't hotels yeah yeah yeah they're my
friggin
apartments but then what happened say if
a massive like premiere inn gets built
yeah is that going to take if a massive
premiere inn wants to build in the area
that just shows the crazy demand
yeah that's perfect thank you bye bye
amazing so we've got our viewing from 20
minutes in windsor um and it's literally
right near the castle did you tell him
it was cool yeah yeah
20 minutes yeah if we get a property
here look at this
there's a hotel
i think i've just put the actual windsor
castle in one stage
my bad i've got one minute to together
oh my goodness we're five minutes away
[Music]
what we basically do is like it's kind
of like a a long term layer and we'll
agree a price today and then obviously
say five seven years time but that's
when the property will go through but in
that time we can obviously rent it out
and we'll give you a little money for
the morning we'll rent it off for one
thousand three hundred five years
um we'll pay you you're up front rent
your upfront deposit but also give you a
three thousand pound option fee which
will come off of the
fifth day yeah if we don't wanna buy it
after four years we need to give you 12
months notice yeah and we lose our
option fee we do buy it then we go ahead
and buy a 450 and we've got
if we don't buy after five years then um
we we lose out yeah yeah that's kind of
standard how we do it isn't it it suits
me because yeah as i say
i've got family problems going on i need
to be here then everywhere and you're
so you want a month's rent upfront which
is 1 300.
five weeks deposit which is gonna be
about one six or or whatever it is up
front and um
and then
yours and then the keys are made great
all right well we'll get your contract
over today and if that's all good to you
yeah then um we'll get the keys
immediately and we can get it
ready and stick it on airbnb let's try
it on it she'll be honest
this evening
as soon as we get home we'll email it
goodness
what do you think
so we need to get him a lease option
agreement contract and our rent to rent
contract
now before we send him a contract we
need to do due diligence on the area to
check that we're definitely going to
make money on this yeah he might be
rubbing his hands together thinking ha
ha suckers yeah so we need to we need to
check the property out
um i did have a quick look
but we need to go and do serious due
diligence and then we need to send him a
contract yeah and then hopefully by the
end of the day you will have not only a
rent to rent but also a lease option
agreement
[Music]
we'll get we'll get a contract with you
today i'm i really want the keys in my
hands within 24 hours
he's excited
i'm a pressure
businessman you're a very pushy landlord
yeah
see you later sean
he says
he sent off a very pushy business man
he didn't know you this morning and now
you're asking
i love that man i love that man to get
back in this field becca's field for
bums
[Music]
hello there my name is alexander price
i'm the local service combination expert
here in windsor i was contacted today by
emilia through open rent and i've agreed
to go through the numbers with her to
help her do the due diligence on a deal
she's looking to do in windsor or
service accommodation
so what do you think of this property
because samuel seems to think we'll be
able to get like maybe a grand a month
profit from it i'd say that's definitely
doable i've seen the property i've seen
the location you know lovely was it
refurbished two bed two bath place with
furniture um the grander profit should
be should be pretty easy i think you
could even be pushing 1500
wow you see to me i'm still like i can't
get my head around it because all i'm
thinking right now is okay i have to
guarantee
a landlord rent and the void period
scare me because obviously if i can't
get this rent
i still have to pay the landlord 100
think about all of the things that are
pointing in your direction right now
yeah there's already hotels on winter
there's already service accommodation um
you've heard from me that we've had
really positive experience this season
yeah and you know the market's moving
towards service accommodation so i think
in a really strong position that's
amazing because you've made me feel a
lot more like confident about it because
yeah hearing that you have 16 now
properties in uh windsor that you're
doing rent essay across the winter
months
yeah that are doing well is um
yeah it's really reassuring so thank you
so much for meeting with me no way
so alex was really um
positive about it he thought he was a
cracking deal and considering he's got
like 16 in the area nice what did you
think about my estimations of the profit
he thought you're a bit low
really yeah and he has literally in the
same like similar area kind of like 16.
okay shall we go ahead
and the landlord is happy i've spoke to
the landlord since okay and he's saying
he wants to the only thing the
landlord's asking for it's a little bit
awkward yeah is the way we positioned it
to him was as if like we had a big
established company
yeah but if you're going to do this in
your have you even got a company
i've set one about a few weeks ago and
uh but obviously i haven't haven't been
a landlord before so i don't have like
like i don't have anything okay
i reckon we can get around that problem
okay we also are gonna have to pay
literally like
tonight we're gonna have to pay one
month's rent up front
we're gonna have to pay
everything we're also about three grand
option fee
it is gonna be about six grand
so
have you got that kind of money knocking
about
um
like
it's one of those things that i could i
could get
but
what do you mean you could get do you
have it in the bank
oh i do but it'd leave me with no like
it'll leave me with hardly anything to
like live up i wouldn't be comfortable
doing how much money you have in the bag
like i have probably about seven grand
but like but perfect
but like i've got expense i've got stuff
to pay i wouldn't feel comfortable kind
of putting that all but you're going to
make a grand a month off of this i know
but obviously i've
obviously i thought we were going to do
like no money down
and i feel like that would be better
like i'd rather like get somebody
involved because i haven't got i haven't
got the references anyway so it's like
why don't i okay so you want to watch
co-rent your rent
yeah okay
who are you going to bring in
um
no why
no why
okay i i don't think it's a bad idea to
current event with very much we've got
on a lease option agreement as well i
understand at least they're gonna at
least it leaves us with more money for
tomorrow's deal very much we're gonna be
getting a deal every day every single
day yes i just feel like
yeah i just felt like
the math isn't math like if i'm doing a
deal a day yeah somebody was like six
grand did it like
but money all right
drop a message drop a message on the
facebook group and just say i've got a
deal does anyone want to team up with me
i'm looking for someone that's got
experience in mentioning it's got a
company set up yeah that's got six grand
and we can do a deal
and okay you'll be absolutely
bombarded
uh
put it on the group okay let's do it
facebook and instagram are down um i've
never known anything like this for this
long and i'm literally patient because i
don't know what i'm gonna do obviously i
was meant to post the deal on facebook
and samuel's on a business meeting now
um so i don't really know what i'm gonna
do i tried to mention it to him and he
was just like oh i'll see if i can get
people around um so he's got evans
coming round um and i'm basically gonna
have to pitch to him
but
you know i thought i was gonna be able
to post on facebook and have loads of
leads and people i can talk to but now i
have one basically opportunity because i
need to get everything signed and sorted
tonight and the landlord's waiting um
and i don't want him to like you know i
don't want him to snatch the deal back
because he gets like a bit worried or
whatever so
i'm stressed i'm probably not making
much sense
but yeah i'm very scared because i know
evans from like pitching him on the
eviction but i've never done like
business with him and i know he's a hard
negotiator
[Applause]
amelia is nervous
hey guys there man thanks for coming out
all right
all right so basically situation um
amelia
has got a really good deal today
but
she needs a little bit of support with
her
so
she thought you guys might be able to
potentially help her out but obviously
if there is a good deal or what way
as in potentially invest in it it's only
a renter
lease option went to man you'll like it
okay
so yeah what do you what do you guys
think yeah you know we know the area so
that deal i mean that still stacks for
sure i mean the deal looks good um well
i'm just struggling to find out how how
is this going to work out as a joint
venture how are we going to structure it
i'm probably going to need around six
grand to set it up with legals and
obviously like sorting right around
furniture all that kind of stuff
and i don't have that money
realistically now to be putting into the
deal so what i'm looking for is a joint
venture partner that comes on board puts
a six thousand pound in and i'm happy to
kind of take the cash flow that's coming
in monthly um and leave the lease option
side to
the joint venture partner so they'd get
all of the the capital appreciation as
the property kind of goes up um
that's kind of the deal that i'm hoping
to to secure
so we put the money in you manage it you
get all the cash flow you get all the
capital appreciation yes
and how would the reference thing work
as well so obviously i right now don't
have any kind of landlord experience but
i know obviously you guys have like
essays in the in the area um so
obviously i'm hoping with the joint
venture part that comes on that's why
you guys i feel like you guys will be
perfect and because we can use you you
know your
landlord so we use so it's obviously put
through our company our reference thing
and then we'd put the money in
yeah and then we'd get you'd get all the
cash flow and we'd get the capital
appreciation yes definitely so obviously
even if that property goes up by 10
that's 45 000
you a lot of time to get from the from
the cash flow angle
how long have you secured it over
security for five years five years
yeah
we need to get the contract signed
tonight at night i know that
a little bit of
pressure um but
we need to get inside tonight
um
so you know how does that sound
i think it manages to
just sleep on it probably just come back
to you in the morning
it's just a lot to think about no no i
definitely i appreciate that i'm just
wondering what
what could i say now to make you kind of
sign
sign the deal tonight
yeah i mean the deal definitely stacks
it's definitely really good we know the
area we've got a few exits in the area
as well our you know our only hurdle is
the fact that we have multiple agents
throwing deals out so we just
it's just a bit like you know for us to
put the money in get a cash flow to be
like we can just find one ourselves
that's our only
you know hurdle um
not sure
would you
yeah well um this landlord is he has a
few properties i'm surprised i've
actually not come across him kind of yet
because he's got quite a few properties
in the windsor area so he's really open
to kind of doing future business um you
know he was a pretty easy landlord to
pitch compared to some people that i
talked to earlier today um
and i honestly think if this property
goes well he'll be open to doing kind of
more
more property deals you know he even
said like he's got one that he's looking
to kind of sell
and for tax reasons he's kind of needs
to do it kind of slowly so the lease
option
model actually really works for him um
because he can obviously do a delayed uh
completion so i think it's a really
positive kind of both joint venture
hopefully and also kind of a uh
relationship with him as well the
landlord
i think probably would just probably
just need
to sleep on it what do you think just
yeah i like we absolutely we do really
want to help and your point is super you
know don't think we're brushing out your
points we're not we're just we're just
gonna i just think
just to like because it's a big decision
you know we're entering into business
together
[Music]
what could i
say so we
have to be on the table today
well do you wanna should we just take
like a few minutes like 15 minutes or
something then and then we can just have
a quick chat
that was uh interesting
my head's like pounding
i'm stressed it was very tense
that was so tight i feel like it's
awkward when you're doing like because
obviously i kind of
say they were friends like you know i
mean they're friends so it's like doing
business with your friends like
it's a bit stressful
it's very stressful
oh god i hope they say yeah i'm actually
fully stressed
actually
oh if they don't say yes
i don't know what i'm gonna do
like i literally don't know what i'm
gonna do facebook is down
i can't
it literally what am i gonna do
i need to get sorted tonight
i'll try we already got much time today
you were proposing that we would do all
the legals and all the investment for
the lease option
yeah so that you guys have your names on
it and i wouldn't touch that side of it
so we'd be bringing that investment and
all that
what do you what do you think of it
i'm i mean i'm happy with whatever your
decision is
it's a lot to process but we do want to
help you you know we love you
so you guys have the least options
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely awesome yeah
so
if you're going to do a deal a day
where you wanna go tomorrow
so
i don't know whether to obviously i've
got the one in windsor i've now got one
in clapham i don't know whether to stay
in london
what's the end goal what do you really
want to achieve like here's the thing
with you
you're actually a decent job yeah
employed by a really sexy guy
great boss great trying to quit
you know but but what's the are you
doing this because and if you are
it's totally cool yeah but are you
trying to get out
working
are you going to retire i'm retiring if
you are good honestly in all seriousness
if you are yeah i'm totally cool with
that and you don't even have to give me
an answer now but i'm just wondering
like
and it's a bit of an awkward
conversation i'm just like wondering
what's the end goal like do you want to
be doing because rent to rent
they do take a little bit of effort yeah
like you've got we've now got two rental
rents you can easily do that on top of a
job but if we get a rent to rent every
day you end up with 10 window rents like
realistically
yeah
is it a high paid job maybe more paid
than you
but it's kind of like a job like what's
the
what's the end goal
so i feel like i've always said to
myself
like obviously now i've got the class
over it so that's amazing because you're
gonna make like two grand a month yeah
that's insane that is much that's what
basically makes you financially free in
two days literally that was my goal for
i'm turning 25 in january that was my
goal for them to have like 25 yeah at
least yeah where we got 24. what should
what what what's the goal well by 30 i
obviously want to have like a property
yeah yeah
i think third yeah because obviously i
need to save from these restaurants to
them
no no no no no
yeah just say oh you can just borrow
money
good debt baby yeah
i think as well i don't think i'd want
to buy and look like i'd want to so
obviously from manchester united yeah
and i'd want to because it the price has
gone up so high now i want to get it
whilst i can and get a property in
manchester like just around where i grew
up like usually okay so your goal to buy
a home to live in
well i'm i'm there like half time
manchester half time don't want to live
in london i don't want to be in
manchester i'll see you for the job
could you buy a house
could you buy a house in manchester on a
residential mortgage
yeah
put down a small deposit okay live in it
residential house part-time okay
and then put lodges
in the rooms
rent the rooms out you'll pay no tax
when you sell the property you'll pay no
capital gains tax okay
i recommend you go to manchester i
recommend you go to manchester
and i reckon we need to find a house for
you and if we if you if we find the deal
but does that mean i have to look
because i i like i do like living it i
feel like i need to live in london for
the job and obviously
you're moving between both at the moment
yeah yeah yeah but the moment you're
staying at your mom's and you've got
your house sherry thing it's just
obviously the money that i need to put
down for the house oh i think let's go
to manchester united let's find a house
our food has come oh this looks
beautiful
yes thank you for fighting for us in the
kitchen
i tried not to listen too much but i had
a little tiny bit thank you big tip
coming tonight baby so so
you're living at the moment kind of in
between manchester and london yeah and
the thing is i love london but it's so
tempting right now i could go and
because how much how much ranger
so i paid 9.50 but obviously
i don't for a lot of my job at the
minute i'm working at home so it's like
i could go to burnley and be in a potty
for like 300 pounds it's so tempting
but then it's like i want to be in
london and i want to be in a nice way
you should stay in london yeah but you
go to manchester at the weekends yeah
i reckon you want to get on the property
ladder you want to buying in manchester
is smart yeah
capital appreciation the market's
booming yeah houses are much cheaper
i reckon we go to manchester
i reckon we buy a property
we use someone else's money
residential property you stay there at
the weekends and then you rent the rooms
out to lodges
yeah got it i reckon we can find that
ice tomorrow
you can find a property tonight well
we'll see man i'm just trying to say in
london
what have you ever thought about house
packing
what's that
house hacking so for instance at the
moment you pay 950 pounds a month yeah
and you're in a decent flat yeah it's
okay
you could find
a big beautiful luxurious
apartment or penthouse canary wharf
three bed
three grand a month
okay
and rent one of the rooms out for 1500
because big and beautiful in canary
wharf one of the rooms out for 1500 and
then you're living rent-free
in a bigger beautiful apartment
rent-free flat in london
house in manchester that you went out to
lodges residential mortgage
two deals we've done two deals already
that'll be two more deals that will only
be one more deal and we're going to the
other day in five days
that just sounds too good to reach me
house hacking
living rent-free renting out the rooms
in london and could not be done of
course
if that happens
i'll be in service
okay
let's go to manchester first and find
your property to buy okay and then once
we've got that done yeah then we'll go
to london and we'll find a property to
live in house hack tour and we need one
more deal
we'll figure that out we'll figure that
out later
maybe we'll eat
hey by the way i know my glasses kind of
empty
but cheers
cheers to success to financial freedom
[Music]
tomorrow we're actually finding your
house to buy so 7 30 prompt reception
[Music]
[Applause]
so today we're in my home city of
manchester and we're going to be buying
a property with no money
by now in manchester day three no money
down deal
let's go
[Music]
hey
[Music]
how are you doing
hello
thanks for letting us come down to the
house and for assisting as you know
meena's doing a financial freedom
challenge and so far it's been good why
don't you fill them in as to what's
happened so far yeah so obviously we're
on
the morning of day three okay right now
shattered and
so far it's gone well
so i've currently got
a
secured rent to
sa unit in windsor right next to the
castle
which
which i'm going to be making probably
over 800 on maybe probably a lot more
than that
and on top of that on the windsor
prophecy she managed to negotiate with
the landlord and option to buy in five
don't know how you do years the plan is
now
amelia wants to get on the property
ladder i must actually buy a house okay
so
you're 24 yeah turn 25 in january
the goal is before she turns 25 i want
to have the keys so we need to find
something that you can buy
today
ideally
and tell your mom about how we're
planning on structuring it we were
looking for a property whereby obviously
i come back a lot so i really want
somewhere to be able to stay i'll see
you doing projects and i want a base and
somewhere in manchester because
obviously it keeps going from prize
where i can have you know a two three
bed house and rent out the rooms to
lodges and i've got a room for myself
okay
so that's what i'm looking for
um i'm wondering if you can possibly
help
today we then also fingers crossed if we
get time gonna go back to london
tell you about what we're gonna do in
london if we get time i'm hoping to
basically rent a really like beautiful
apartment in london
for about three grand maybe two three
beds
and rent the other rooms out
and live in there myself so i can live
rent free house hacking
three grand beautiful massive red the
rooms out they'll play her around she'll
live rent free in london then have a
house in manchester on a residential
mortgage which you can get lodgers in
you pay zero tax bedroom relief tax so
you're gonna eventually have a free
place in manchester to appreciate in
value a free place in london two rent to
rent which is basically
financial freedom
so we've got a lot of work to do but the
first things first is i think we need to
find a property today
in manchester
that you can actually buy
and get on the property
in the normal to buy
yeah
i've been saving
because i haven't
all across that bridge what i'm thinking
in terms of deposit yeah if we find a
really good house at a good price
standard residential property in
manchester
you'll have to help us find that
the deposit you'll be able to get a
residential mortgage on it because
you're going to live there you're going
to vote in the room you live there so
we'll have to get your decision in
principle
from a broker which we can do like 15
minute flat amazing perfect thank you
andrew
thank you
thank you so much andrew cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can get a mortgage
so you get a mortgage so you can get a
mortgage
now when you see the house i just
thought it was so outrageous
well i'll say i honestly thought like my
time is only going on by 30.
your your mortgage interest rates on
your own
your interest rates on that loan are
gonna be about two percent
it's like free money almost
the deposit we will find believe me if
we find the house
so let's get looking for this damn house
let's go
yeah are you available today
yeah so we're looking for a two bed
property that we can hopefully turn to a
three bed um
for residential purposes
yes perfect
it's underrated
we just booked it too
okay it's amazing
amazing but i've just remembered we've
got viewing a half 10
for that property i was telling you
about last night with blaze
the 10 bed hmo
i know it's not obviously one more now
but
we need to focus though
i've not seen anything about this
property is it good yeah
you're not allowed to buy it though i
know
where is it how does it feel oh my
goodness
okay if possible right why don't you
continue booking appointments for this
afternoon we'll shoot off how fast
okay
do all you can to focus as many of you
this afternoon just go and view them if
you can if you're not back in time
i'll see you in two hours yeah we
arranged something where we we buy the
property for
an agreed amount um in five years time
but in the meantime you want left to buy
yeah so we we will secure a price today
and there will a delayed completion so
i'll see you guys today that'll go
through for example five years three
years time and right now we'll take over
the property and managers will be
completely hassle-free for you and but
then we'll just have a laser completion
yeah i think we're going to take a while
to do it up and get the furniture in so
obviously we'll
we'll hope to have a few months free run
yeah two months free rent because i have
myself six weeks yeah yeah soon come to
life and to get people in it let me let
me talk to my partner because in that
point i'm partnering so in principle
hello hello hello
so
yeah it's going well we have basically
just secured a 10 bed hmo on a lease
option agreement so basically now i'll
be able to put down the deposit oh my
god
it's pretty crazy
question for you though right
have we got have we got any other
viewings today in
all around manchester do you know
i've got two tomorrow one on saturday
and i've got somebody ringing me at one
o'clock today to tell me if we've got
one this afternoon
all right well that's obviously three
minutes time so we'll speak later
okay cheerio hi bye love you
i'm just freaking to see that you're
still okay for your viewing this
afternoon yes yeah perfect
i'll see you soon bye bye bye
julia i'm sitting next to julie now have
you got started he's just doing the
affordability
yeah it fits on 95 percent with at least
one lender
ah amazing news what sort of interest
would be expected to pay what kind of
percent
uh i don't know let's have a look there
here we've gotta find any interest rates
yet on that jury
i mean interest rates for um 95
percenters are not one percent or 1.5 uh
because it's high risk mortgage um
but it'll be
that knowing the lender it'll be
competitive oh she's got it's got the
terms up
[Music]
95
mortgage what the heck
that is incredible i think you're gonna
be able to get that mortgage i really do
that'll be it's like free money man 95
mortgage this house we haven't even seen
it yet but it better be good
i
i like it
part-time living in london part-time in
manchester owning a property this is a
really nice part of manchester as well
isn't it yeah i think
i think it's just
yes so it's on the market for 1.90
[Music]
you could rent out that room
you could rent out this room yeah and
then the downstairs sitting room you
could turn into a bedroom
and live in yourself
i
really needs a little bit of a lift
yeah but
right near your mama's house
what do you think what are you thinking
i'm obsessed you love it
i love it
we should let's just offer on it
i think so
in the street that type of house you're
selling for 200. yeah they're trying to
get a quick offer on it yeah
i would offer one
i would offer one seven nine
one seven nine i reckon it's worth one
nine one nine five
on offer 179
and just tell them you've got your
mortgage in principle you've got your
broker you've got your sister yeah one
second on your offer bank now
it's a really solid house
it's a really good investment
hi my name's emilia and i'm just looking
to put an offer on the property on
yes
so i'm looking to offer 179
000.
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes i'm good thank you how are you
thank you i'm just giving you a quick
call in regards
that is amazing that is such good news
you're going to be a homeowner
oh what do you think
she needs your right hand what you're
going to need now she's going to need
your mortgage in principle which you've
got she's gonna need your photo id which
you got she's gonna do your
correspondence address which we've got
she's gonna need your solicitor's
details which we've got from from the
mortgage broker yeah she's gonna do a
proof of deposit which we haven't quite
got
we need to sell these options agreement
yeah and we need to sell it now
right we need to sell it now
we need to get an extra few thousand in
your bank right freaking now and then
we've got that short deposit sword
but you will have to spend everything
you've got on this deposit yeah
and then the rent to rent we've
obviously negotiated no rent up front
for the time being
i've had the offer accepted on the house
the one
you're joking what did you offer what's
your favorite 179
with a mortgage offering in place
95 percent mortgage
with the
interest rate of two and a half percent
done and dusted
and four
and four thousand pounds
and four thousand pounds
hopefully coming tomorrow from a deal
that we packaged today which will go
towards the very tiny deposit
[Music]
well done
i'm really pleased good job i'll live
down the road
so what you're doing up hmos and phil's
own building site i've got someone to
stay
add somewhere for you if you're playing
yeah
that's unbelievable i can cancel all
these appointments yeah i did when i
said she'll buy something in the next
two days i was being serious
she wants it she's already done it
oh my god yeah that's a great house it
is a great house isn't it yeah
honestly that i'm so thankful
because i literally i couldn't have done
it without you if you you doing the
viewings and when we were going to find
deals honestly
honestly
together
we've got a lot to do yeah
back to london what are you up to
pitching in front of investors tonight
100 investors yeah trying to sell a deal
find a free flat now you've got your
free house
so um we've got about eight so we're
going to shoot
do you want to
take the car
thank you
[Music]
well we've literally got like
um
three minutes okay
so over to my wonderful friend great
person emilia asante
told the samuel 365 family and thank you
for all the support in the comments
towards what we've already done in the
challenge is a 10 bed hmo
lease option agreement
it's incredible they're super super
motivated to sell i've actually i've had
a handshake on it we're still in kind of
negotiations but you said in principle
i'm happy um so that's an incredible
deal um
so yeah i am completely open it's a brr
so there would need to be to be works on
it and i'm looking for a 4 000 pound
finders fee for that deal okay so
someone's just called me it's literally
9 32 we finished two minutes ago three
people have already messaged me and i've
had about three calls as well you can
literally see on here like
hi emilia rosalind here
hey emilia fabian here
hey emilia i'm interesting your deals
give me a call
it's been like three minutes honestly
so i personally think it's very late
yeah so i would probably shake your
speaking tomorrow and then in the
morning i need some training with you
what to say perfect tomorrow's gonna be
dear selling day
so it is
past 11 p.m at night i think samuel
wanted me to go to bed
um
but i've got a lot to do i've gotta
reply to these messages
i've gotta get some contracts drawn up
and hopefully getting to check them over
tomorrow
um so yeah and i've got the call at 6 00
30 in the morning tomorrow
so
it's gonna be a busy time
but yeah i'm just i'm just excited
it is
nearly 3am
in the morning
and i think i need to get some sleep
[Music]
what we'll do
is obviously i've got your email now so
i'll send over a nda and and once
obviously you've signed that that i
think that can send you all the details
um
yeah
so i'm just going to be completely kind
of upfront with kind of where we're at
with the deal and like the situation
with it so it is um the sort of thing
that we are kind of still in
negotiations right now um but the
landlord is completely down for doing
the lease options he's he's actually
reached out to me this morning um
honestly he's reached out about another
deal in them in stevenage so he's
basically got a portfolio that he is
looking to to get rid of
need so um said it needs to be
redecorated
what about what about all the things
like the roof and windows and all these
type of things that doesn't need
outstanding prefer just give me give me
just give me a vision right now right i
have a front garden and a gate
yeah it has like a small kind of a i
wouldn't really call it a garden it's
you know a little path up to that is
like i just don't i actually don't think
we're gonna get it sold today because
people want to go and view it
um
i'm just a little bit worried
tell me what jl said
so
gel's obviously done lots of deals in
the area yeah so she's kind of quite
thorough
and literally knows that all the
questions that you have does it have
planning for a 10 bed yes it does does
it have commercial boiler
i think it does does it have updated
electric unit is it oh my goodness is
there something that are there any
cracks are there any toilet flush at the
fire doors what's the condition of the
roof
okay i just don't feel prepared for it i
feel like i'm getting swamped by
questions
what you need to do is you need to sell
it yeah get four grand yeah sell it and
send some look
give me the money now yeah then you can
go and view it
you can meet the landlord and if you
don't like it
then i'll find you another suitable
property yeah and if i can't do that
then i'll refund you
but i need the money because otherwise
she's like every tom dick and harry
because everyone wants it yeah they just
don't want to pay
yeah yeah but what if what if they do
pay but then they go around and see it
and they don't like it then and then
it's two weeks and then i find someone
else for the landlord
if they if that no one's gonna pay you
four grand for a laugh yeah if they pay
you foreground they're serious yeah they
pay you four brands yeah let them go
look at it and if they don't like it
offer them either six weeks to find a
replacement or a refund and for the
landlord's sake
will they be annoyed that i'd have to
bring somebody else in i don't think
they were if they pay four brand they're
going to go ahead
unless the deal sucks in which case you
don't want to sell anywhere but it
doesn't suck because we've seen it yeah
call jay again and say to gl i can't
answer all your questions but what i can
do is i can show you around the property
you're going to love it you're going to
meet the landlord i don't know how many
how many electric sockets are in
the rooms
but let's go and have a look at it but i
need your money to show me that you're
serious how would you like to pay
oh i'm not sure if i can put the funny
clubs in i'll give you a contract with
terms and conditions that samuel is put
together which is going to protect you
to mean you're entitled to a refund if
you don't other property or and i'll
become your personal property finder for
six weeks and i'll find a suitable
replacement how does that sound great
how would you like to pay
okay
go on just do your best shot and if they
don't want to pay then next you've got
about 15 people to call yeah and i
honestly i i really think this deal
would be would be perfect for you um and
i want to do business with you long term
and so i was just going to be like you
know how do you feel about that
i mean yeah absolutely you know
i think you're amazing so i would love
to do business with you
yeah no that that's amazing amazing
because what i'm thinking now
like here's what i think needs to happen
now like i would love to show you kind
of around the property um
but i would need to reserve it for the
four thousand pound fee
um and what i can do is obviously i'll
send over the terms and conditions and
that basically says if there's any
problems um
you know you're entitled to a full
refund but first i would love the
opportunity and if it does fall through
and to have like a six week period of
being your personal property finder and
finding you you know another amazing
deal should this one not go through
yeah absolutely i mean look you know
i know you and you know i definitely
want to work with you
i think you know i definitely would want
to see the property
and i definitely you know would want to
know
join the club
you know a small amount of that you know
the amazing profit that you'll make and
obviously there's so many people that
really want this deal right now and i'm
basically calling around people because
i've had similar kind of conversations
and and now i'm just you know
whoever basically makes sense the the
finest fee
um
which under obviously the term the
conditions that we said you know it will
be funded from the world if it does fall
through or should you not be happy with
it
i mean what do you envision is
you're an expert in the area you know i
think i think it's good for you to see
because i don't know even how much
you'd want to how nice you'd want to
refer but for example and so obviously
that that would be the sort of thing
that it would be best i wouldn't want to
put a figure on it um but obviously we
will go around the property and i'll get
you a viewing as soon as possible and
she still got the address
14 people want to see
run down it
have a look at it do my own calculation
and then like once you need to
pre-qualify people everyone wants to see
it
is that is that something that you're
bullshitting
well yeah is it literally so many people
that kind of want to i've even got you
know some investors in huddersfield that
are also wanting to see it and so
obviously for me to to work and
obviously this one as well it's still in
negotiation period so basically i just
want to secure
they want to get it and then from there
i can be just directly that one person
and negotiate with them because this is
the investor they're having they're
coming for another viewing this is the
person that's going to be buying it and
then it's kind of because i don't want
to basically with the landlord be like
there's this person coming to see it
because already we had a few of us there
the other day um
honestly i think you know i honestly
think this will be perfect for you so
i'll send over the terms and conditions
and the bank details and
you know we'll get moving
yeah
honestly honestly congratulations
because it's you know it's a brilliant
deal and you know people are going to be
very sad when i'm telling them it's not
available and you're looking forward to
working on it and i'm looking forward to
working together so amazing thank you so
much no worries thank you
meet you soon
[Applause]
how does it feel
it's scary it's a lot of responsibility
it's a lot of responsibility because
it's you know the reason why when you
when someone's paying you money the
reason why they're paying you is for
value and also the responsibility and
trust and
it's a lot but we still secured the deal
yesterday yeah and it's a really good
deal but you've got an exit strategy if
it falls out of bed yeah and then you've
got another rating strategy and it's all
going to be written in terms of
conditions so that she's safe you're
safe
so
well done kill
you killed it
is like
racing
i need to get this scent over to her
conditions yeah and get them signed asap
okay
so
it is nearly
6 p.m
and i have been on admin all day um
this probably isn't usual for like a
financial freedom challenge
but it has to be done like we've done so
many deals at the start of the week that
i was getting chase contracts and all
sorts so today i've basically just been
on like deal selling and admin and so
i'm just going to give a rundown of kind
of where i'm up to the rent to hmo in
clapper uh the ball is out of my core
i've sent the contracts over the renter
sa deal in windsor we're just waiting to
hear back from the landlord and have
everything signed so i can get the keys
which is amazing and i'm so excited
about it and then also often can i send
in my details to the property from
yesterday that i'm buying so yeah it's
been a
ad mini paperwork kind of boring day but
it is so important because if you don't
you'll lose deals if you're not on it
with your paperwork um so yeah
it's super important
but i'm just hoping that i get paid
tonight
from the deal that i'm selling
my name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness
she's been deal
sourcing like a proper girlfriend
hello
on monday i secured a rent to rent hmo
in london
done signed on tuesday
there's more
i secured a lease option agreement
service accommodation deal
done
then on wednesday i secured my own
property that i'm buying oh my god 479
000.
and how i'm gonna finance that u.s yeah
with a 95 mortgage
on 2.5 percent interest
free money yeah
and then
i got signed by jl a non-disclosure
agreement because she liked a deal that
i found wow
and she signed a turning condition whose
terms and conditions mine and santiage
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is incredible honestly i can't it's not
real i feel like i'm in a dream
is it time for a drink or we've got more
we've got more to do tomorrow
more to do tomorrow baby
i've got at least
day today amelia's going to get some
keys become financially free
bye
when i get the keys it will feel real i
feel like that'll be the bit when i'm
like okay sign it's sealed it's
happening yes
yeah it will it will feel real
let's get those keys in baby hey
hiya
good to see you guys
good to meet you oh yeah
so will the contract start officially on
the first but we'll be able to get the
we'll be able to start doing stuff this
month
this is exciting
you are you are a landlady it's official
amazing thank you so much
it's all starting to it's starting to
feel really
[Music]
that's a good thing man
i think this is the newest building
involving all the wharf okay it's been
built by canola world contractors
highest quality
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yeah so both the rooms are exactly the
same size what's what's the wardrobe's
facing that's one biggest the biggest
one if you can see anywhere okay
how tall it is
literally two times bigger than the
other two two one sweet man look at this
imagine this from just a long swing
this is yeah this is one of the biggest
around massive
we've got a few different ones we're
looking at obviously
we want to do business with you
but um
should we have a little quick chat and
then we can maybe of course i'll let you
guys talk about it
just tell them exactly what you want to
do
to be up front
completely
over the top courageous okay
this is what i'm going to do
oh wow
you got the inside area outside the area
super nice yeah look at that this is
yeah all the buildings can all walk
around you with massive attention
shows with the real housewives over
there as well
how did you get here like celebrities
and
well obviously celebrities you got
always in kenya if you got celebrities
leaving around because of the safety it
just suits you it suits you you have to
live here
you got loads of professional people
working kind of bankers accountants
people working in finance you know
mostly you get nice people you don't
have rough people around or i don't know
people that you're going to enjoy living
with them take the money
so i just want to say firstly thank you
for showing us around because it has
been a bit last minute you know probably
you know samuel it pulled a few strings
but i just wanted to completely level
with you about what i'm having to do
with the flat
so
obviously the three bed is beautiful and
i would i would love to take that on and
i'd love to live there myself and
basically rent out the other two rooms
okay um
and hopefully at a price that would mean
i'm living rent-free if not close to
that
okay well to be honest most of the
landlords were the agree to that
but as it happens
this landlord would i know him we could
saw yeah
price wise he's looking for 3.5
it's a bit high but how much do you
think that the rooms would run out
individually i reckon 13 1300 easily in
a place like this yeah easily
okay so 13 30 it's
like
i would need it like a lot
cheaper to be i mean do the strategy we
could walk that out
obviously 3.5 is not quite sad we're
going to give it some more
we might could saw it at around 3.2
or 3.1 definitely nothing less than that
what what is if you
what what's the lowest the lowest you
could pay for a good tenant
clean young professionals and also when
is it available from when's january
january next year yeah so we can
literally get get it lined up ready
that's good you know you've got three
months time to rent out the rooms
actually so you know when you're moving
you've got the people ready you don't
need to pay the first month when yeah
they're finding the people so the only
issue right now
is the
price
uh
we could work that out
i think
honestly 2 800
is that something that
the landlord would be interested in to
800 would literally mean that we'd
achieved you'd be a hero
and it would mean that we've achieved
the ultimate goal really isn't it yeah i
mean i have to talk with the lander i
knew that i would accept for a good
tenant
i mean older than like that they prefer
to have a good tenant they don't mind
getting a lower price yeah i think we
could work it out i think we could walk
and if we could have worked out on this
three bet
would you personally help me find
another property
look around
hundreds of factory apartments
if not yeah the 100 other properties
that i could sort out for you what do
you think of the idea of the house
hacking idea of renting a property and
then renting out the rooms
amazing absolutely amazing why should
you pay crazy rent yeah then you could
rent free what about references wise
obviously she's doing a good job
well um i think she's going to post the
references
based on the information that she gave
me
but maybe maybe we need a guarantor
maybe
which if you find your talent
before we start we could use one of them
for the reference i'm sure with samuel
i'm sure because he could help i'm sure
we could got a bit of money i'm sure
yeah oh brother you know what i
appreciate you so much for helping him
out because this is like a dream come
true for amelia so i'm sure she would
kill it
the information that you're gonna get
oh my god i'm just thinking about it now
you're gonna do the same thing you're
gonna win yeah no i thought about it i
was like with the information that she
gonna get and i'm gonna get
well we're gonna kill it yeah honestly
we're gonna kill it don't worry about it
you're gonna rent them out
nice price
maybe you need to pay five six hundred
pounds
which is nothing
yeah just area yeah of course about 900
pounds
every month you know yeah so definitely
definitely get to do business with all
of you
and i'm sure you're gonna enjoy it
you're going to love it
no no
thank you to you this week
it's literally been the best week of my
life like the best week of my life i'm
so glad well done i don't know but thank
you to you because on it like i just
honestly i don't think you would like i
don't think you understand like how much
[Music]
we need to celebrate yeah
we're gonna go to the club we'll go home
[Music]
feels good baby
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going yeah really good thank
you i'm literally just in the winter
property now it's been full every day
since i got it so this is the first time
i was like let me come down whilst
there's like the window between cleaning
hang on so when you got the keys
yeah
you listed it how long did it take to
start getting people coming in
the day that i've got the keys was the
day that i had the first guest
oh my god i wouldn't recommend it but it
worked and i've been getting good
reviews so i got my first review
i'm so happy well done and it's been
fully booked literally every night
literally every night
the location is incredible
what about the other deals clapper how's
everything what's happening yeah so
they're clapping one it's now full um
initially when i took it over i thought
one tenant was moving out and it was
actually three so initially i was a
little bit like oh a bit worried but i
wasn't like
like two weeks like the rooms are just
going crazy and the reference is like
profit-wise yeah what are you thinking
over the two uh over the clapham and the
wins property no less than 1 500. what's
what's happening on the on the deal
sourcing side of things
yes so the deal is that sold in the week
and it's still up in the air with the
landlord at the minute so it's not 100
confirmed um however i've got loads of
uh juicy deals in the pipeline and i've
also got a joint venture partner um and
we're looking for a deal to do together
maybe like a commercial to residential
uh which is really exciting
and and also in the last few weeks like
since the challenge and cash eight
thousand pound i've made uh for a deal
so yeah
yeah yeah mortgage offers in and yeah
it's it's progressing so i'm really
happy with it and otherwise i know you
took um a week off and then the
following week as well you had to clean
up every all the mess that we had
and get everything systemized um
what's what's what what's the plan
i feel like
i love entrepreneurship and i love
having a business but i also love
career progression and i love the
company and i just think
yeah i just think i'd want to stay
around a little bit longer if you'll
have it
so i retired for you just to come back
anyway
we'll do a full proper sit-down
45-minute interview about exactly what
happened and what you're doing so if
anyone wants to see that
subscribe i'm sure you'll be okay to do
a sit-down interview of course and in
all seriousness well done it's just a
joy to have been working with you and
seeing you become a property
entrepreneur and financially free 24
years old
oh thank you so much it wouldn't have
been possible obviously without your
help and it's just been
it's just been a crazy time and i can't
wait to for other people to hear the
story
[Music]
the people really want to know who i
stop and steal when is see me if a city
wants no need to repeat run up on me
watch you fall to your knees tip my head
when it's time for the kill ain't no
beast when you're really real i am the
boss i am the dawn i am the one they
call lucky charm got my own [ __ ] i don't
need your farm life was so hard it made
me weak built to last this girl ain't
weak sturdy and still when i plant my
feet got it out the mill and i was
racking my sleep look to god he supplies
my needs endless faith is what brought
me next level prosperity